what is oh my gosh this is I'm going to
be an auntie
De Brat shocks pal Sherry Shepard
revealing she's pregnant
now we're gonna have a baby
48 year old rapper and her wife Judy
shared their happy news Tuesday on
Sherry's talk show how far along are you
we are 18 weeks five months
[Applause]
she better pass my first semester
yeah I didn't get nauseous or anything
the brat also displayed her growing baby
bump on Instagram posting a series of
sweet photos her belly on full display
we're excited
our the bear hasn't been shy about their
dream of expanding their family after
tying the knot a year ago so where are
we at on the baby rat or baby Judy
journey is there a timeline we'll say
this we we well we started to discuss
this we didn't realize
um
how many different hurdles can kind of
come in a way we're excited we are where
we are we'll give that we are very
excited where we stand as of today but
there just has been quite a few hurdles
that we have not been open with social
media or anybody about yeah the health
reasons yeah but we are excited the two
even predicted what kind of mother Da
Brat will be I'm gonna be very hands on
she has already said nobody can hold a
baby I'm like yeah
people people visit like they can wash
their hands no but you can't breathe on
my baby
I don't want your lips on my baby
all that stuff that is for us okay
no Judy's their reason why y'all decided
that Brad would carry the baby as
opposed to you well you know her I feel
like her leading character trait is
being nurturing so I felt like that she
needed to have the experience I've I've
birthed three children yeah so which is
why I feel like it would be easier for
her
no because her body's used to it she's
had three so she had one more to just
slide on out
the ladies also explain why they're not
finding out the baby's sex before he or
she arrives like you know you get your
eggs extracted they're able to sell the
gender stuff but we chose to let them do
it blind just in case we go through all
of them and then for some reason we
don't have the gender that we wanted so
we just want a healthy baby
congrats to the happy couple on their
bundle of joy
[Music]
good
foreign